In this segment we introduce
the concept of
a confidence interval.
The starting point is that an
estimate, the value of an
estimator, does not tell
the whole story.
One option is to also provide
the standard error of the
estimator, but a more common
practice is to report a
confidence interval.
What is that?
We'll introduce the notion
of a confidence
interval through a story.
You're working for a
polling company.
You carry out a poll, and then
you go and report to your boss
that my estimate is this
particular number.
And then your boss says, I
appreciate the five digit
accuracy, but are your
conclusions that accurate?
You go back to your desk, you do
some more calculations, and
then you tell your boss, here is
a 95% confidence interval.
Your boss tells you, that looks
great, but what does
that exactly mean?
You go back to your textbook,
you pull out the definition,
and you reply as follows.
Well, a 95% confidence
interval--
so here I am letting
alpha to be 5%--
a 95% confidence interval is
an interval that has the
following property.
That the unknown value of the
parameter that we're trying to
estimate falls inside
this interval with
probability at least 95%.
And if you wish, I could also
let alpha be equal to 1%, in
which case I could give you
a 99% confidence interval.
Your boss replies, no,
that sounds good.
A 95% interval sounds fine.
And your boss goes out to
the press, holds a press
conference, and reports that
the true value of the
parameter lies inside this
range, inside the reported
confidence interval with
probability at least 95%.
Does this statement
make sense?
Actually, no.
This statement is the most
common misconception of what a
confidence interval is.
To see why this statement
does not make
sense, look at it carefully.
We're talking about the
probability of something.
But that something does not
involve anything random.
0.3 and 0.52 are just numbers.
And theta is also a number which
we do not know what it
is, but it is not random.
It is a constant.
So this statement is incorrect
on a purely syntactic basis.
I mean the true parameter theta
either is inside this
interval, or it is not.
But there's nothing random here,
and so this statement
does not make sense.
Instead, let us look carefully
at this definition.
This statement does make
sense because it
involves random variables.
The lower and the upper end of
the confidence interval are
quantities that are determined
by the data, and therefore
they are random.
So we do have random
variables in here.
And so it makes sense to talk
about probabilities.
To really understand what's
going on, think as follows.
We're dealing with a poll that
is trying to estimate some
unknown value, theta.
You carry out the poll, and you
come up with a confidence
interval based on the data.
You might be lucky, and your
confidence interval happens to
capture the true parameter.
You carry the poll one more
time, maybe on another day.
You come up with another
confidence interval.
And you're again lucky, and it
captures the true parameter.
You carry it on another day,
and you come up with a
confidence interval.
And maybe the data that you
got were kind of skewed.
You were unlucky, and your
confidence interval does not
capture the true parameter.
Having a 95% confidence interval
means that 95% of the
time, 95% of the polls that you
carry out will capture the
true parameter.
So the word 95% really talks
about your method of
constructing confidence
intervals.
It's a method that 95%
of the time will
capture the true parameter.
It is not a statement about the
actual numbers that you
are reporting on one
specific poll.
So it is important to keep this
in mind, and to always
interpret confidence intervals
the correct way.
So how does one come up with
confidence intervals?
The most common method
is based on normal
approximations, as we
will be seeing next.